you're not going to keep your last name
but then our family's name runs out yeah
there's two girls only two girls yeah
the only two girls well that's the way
things shake out right I mean your your
family's name is either going to be your
husband's name or your father's name or
why because that's what your last name
is but why can't I want to keep my
father's last name so I'll just keep my
father's last name if I get married
why Fiona Flynn have you heard that
that's a great that's a nice name I'm
not you know I have friends who married
guys with horrible last names but it's
kind of weird
when you get married you would keep your
father's last name no no you wouldn't I
wanted she's talked about it
unless the last name unless the last
name is really awesome
yeah I like my last name too doesn't
that feel like you're not really getting
married then no you're not really
forming no I mean if you're devoted to
each other in every way possible I don't
think it's very trivial part of it your
name is Rich it's what you are called